adolf hitler in minecraft hakenkreuze im
videospiel werden games von nazis
missbraucht solche fragen nerven fast
alle die spielen auch unsere
interviewpartner die medien dieses jahr
schon mal ein bisschen verkackt fast
schon sicher ist eine große streamen und
wollte erst nicht mit uns sprechen
gaming und medien irgendwie ein
schwieriges verhältnis
die behauptungen dass die presse mich
sachlich über computerspiele berichtet
ist tatsächlich auch gar nicht so
unbegründet ein ego-shooter nacht noch
kein killer trotzdem games terror und
rechte irgendwas scheint ja dran zu sein
es bestehen auch durchaus überlappungen
zwischen keine der videospiel szene und
teilen der rechtsextremen szene
rechtsextreme nutzen games um anhänger
zu gewinnen und propaganda zu verbreiten
irgendwer ist schon die wochen im
computerspiel und rechte terroristen
inszenieren ihre taten wie ein
computerspiel sommer 2020 die entdecken
werbung für dieses neue jobs
games vor dem technik loyalisten in
harmlos wirkende retro-optik kämpfen die
gamer innen für die rettung der heimat
feinde sind jan böhmermann oder auch das
zdf so genannte mainstream-medien die
spielhelden zum beispiel afd politik
agieren hecke oder auch rechtsextreme
aktivisten wie martin senner das feld
mit safran eingestand access raums wenn
man dass diese trägt martin selber ist
sprecher der identitäten bewegung in
österreich selber erhielt eine
vierstellige spende vom späteren
christchurch attentäter afd politiker
als computerspielfiguren
rechtsextremismus als lustiges jump n
run
warum von ihm erhoffen wir uns eine
antwort darauf christian hupertz gaming
experte und nerd ich glaube nach der
offiziellen noch mit latour wäre ich ein
gag also ich finde das medium toll ich
beschäftige mich viel damit ich weiß
viel darüber habe aber auch noch viele
andere interessen
die kultur und gaming experte hält
vorträge um die gaming szene zu erklären
gaming kultur hat kein nazi probleme
aber einzelne subkulturen der gerne
kultur haben sicherlich ein problem
damit es dort einerseits aus dem
rechtsradikalismus verwendung finden
oder eben auch spiele produziert werden
eine ganz klare rechtsextremer agenda
verfolgen heimat defender sei nun ja ein
ziemlich durchschaubarer propaganda
versuchen das spiel weil ich für ein
recht mittelmäßiges spiel die identität
bewegung rechnet natürlich wenn sie so
eine aktion wie dieses spiel startet
auch damit dass das eventuell gegenwind
gibt und er ist eingepreist so wird
vielleicht sogar ein stück weit erhofft
er hier ist eine der figuren im spiel
alexander
nennt sich selbst maleki
er ist einer der führenden köpfe der
identitäten bewegung in deutschland
die organisation ist rechtsextrem sagt
der verfassungsschutz
die einheimischen deutschen franzosen
den berlin im eigenen land zur
minderheit ein rechtsextremer aktivist
als figur im jump n run geben
warum macht er das das wollen wir mal
enke selbst fragen bevor er mit uns
redet postet er aber zuerst diese
umfrage auf twitter 57 prozent stimmen
für rede nicht mit der jugendpresse du
gesagt hat er trotzdem ich habe mich
tatsächlich gegen den rat von
rechtsmitteln schiene bin heute mit
ihnen im gespräch mit den niedersten
journalisten ist auch gar kein problem
über das spiel redet man denke gerne mit
uns das für mich natürlich ein große
ehre dass ich meine wir irgendwie schaut
wer ist schon gegossen im computerspiel
dabei kann er mit dem game selbst nicht
viel anfangen dabei hatte ferner
tatsächlich nicht durchgespielt weil ich
selbst mit meinem eigenen charakter er
der beste ist natürlich am ersten der
besteuerung
gamer ist er selbst gar nicht games sind
für die identitäten nur ein tool um
rechte parolen und ideologien
gesellschaftsfähig zu machen
hipster bad statt springerstiefel
identität stadt raste game stadt
flugplatz ist das nicht doch ein
offensichtlicher trägt denn sie darf
erfolgen dass sie interpretiert was sie
für ein und sie unterstellen dass ein
gewisser weise setzten sie sich ja für
mich schon sagen ja bei dem spiel wo sie
eine rolle spielen da ist die und ihre
die die strategie dahinter gewesen das
habe ich immer nur von menschen wie das
hat mich vom spiele entwickler noch nie
gehört der spieleentwickler sagt das
hier öffentlich auf youtube und ja es
ist ein klassisches meter politisches
projekt am ende also kommen extrem gut
inhalte vermitteln und botschaften
vermitteln auf lustige humorvoll meter
politik der lieblings begriff der neuen
rechten soll heißen politik verpackt in
kultur klamotten musik
ausgebucht oder eben computerspielen
unser gaming experte und gi christian
hubert kennt solche versuche gamer zu
politisieren
in den usa hat es schon mal geklappt
gamer geht gamer geld gilt so ein
bisschen als sein großer erweckung
moment wo zum ersten mal sichtbar wurde
wie rechtsextreme akteure aktiv
innerhalb der gaming kultur ja machen
neuen menschen neuen personal
neumitgliedern geschickt haben viel
männlichen gamern ging es um sich darum
dass frauen ihn angeblich ihre spiele
wegnehmen zogen die männer gegen
zockende frauen und die rechte springt
auf gamer geht
wir haben das neue für euch in gta
nachgebaut 2014
immer mehr frauen spielen die gaming
community wird bunter und das sollen
auch die spiele werden
frauen wollen nicht nur sexy randfiguren
in games seien männliche gamer während
sich massiv unter dem hashtag gamer geht
trollen sie gamerinnen und
entwicklerinnen sie verbreiten
desinformation hass und mord drohungen
der frauenhass schweiz zusammen die
extreme rechte erkennt ihre chance und
umarmt die gamer die amerikanische old
white entsteht der gamer aufstand wird
zumindest in teilen politisch
dass vor 2014 fühlt sich weit weg an was
merkt man davon heute noch
wir reden mit streamings saison
sie hat 150 tausend abonnenten auftritt
und katzen ist eine smarte eigentlich
nie und jetzt plötzlich denkt da ab ins
bild eigentlich ist das community eine
ganz schöne heile babbel doch hater gibt
es auch hier also zum einen beleidigen
die ganz gerne
zum beispiel werden irgendwas nicht so
gut gespielt war in dem spiel wenn man
das ja vielleicht irgendwie anders
machen sollen in deren meinungen und
deren augen oder natürlich auch gibt es
auch dass leute mich einfach nur
beleidigen aufgrund dessen dass ich
weiblich bin
es gibt auch okay frauen hassen gaming
immer noch ein thema zum beispiel bei
ganz großen die montana black weil ich
alles gelernt haben ist folgendes frauen
sind wie hunde und das meine ich nicht
abwürgt
neben dem rauen ton auch noch die nazis
warum gibt es generell nazis bzw
jahrhunderts ist warum gibt es die das
problem ist dass die online einfach ein
medium haben in dem sie sich treffen
können ohne sich wirklich treffen zu
müssen und halt auch dieses gefühl
wieder der anonymität haben so erzählt
ihre eigenen streams sein nazifrei auf
der plattform steam sei das anders
ich weiß auch dass sich die leute da oft
unpassenden namen geben oder ein
hakenkreuz in ihren namen eigentlich ist
ihm eine verkaufsplattform für spiele
sie wird aber immer mehr zur community
mit chats gruppen und foren
wir finden gruppen der identitäten
bewegungen anderer rechter nach wenigen
minuten sogar profile mit namen wie die
killer oder kebab rimowa rechtsextreme
organisation und menschenverachtende
nutzernamen ganz offen kaum versteckt
aber worte und namen im internet sind
das eine taten in der echten welt das
andere
jüngstes und extremes beispiel stefan
walid der attentäter von halle
er scheitert beim versuch in eine
synagoge einzudringen ermordet zwei
menschen
der 28-jährige radikalisierte sich
online auch auf der plattform steam das
kommt während seines prozesses raus wir
stoßen auf seine alten nicknames und
finden sein mutmassliches profil auch
ein jahr nach der tat ist es noch online
der attentäter spielte hunderte stunden
ego shooter und war online mit rechten
gesinnungs kameraden verletzt
genau wie andere attentäter von 2009/10
christchurch neuseeland ein
rechtsextremer tötet bei einem angriff
auf zwei moscheen 51 menschen er
inspiriert weitere täter immer sind es
junge männer immer fast der gleiche
tathergang im point kalifornien kommt
bei einem anschlag auf eine synagoge ein
mensch ums leben
el paso texas hier gibt es 22 todesopfer
wer um norwegen wieder ein anschlag auf
eine moschee
und zuletzt halle stefan bald hinterließ
eine art spielanleitung die er ins netz
stellte und inszenierte seinen anschlag
wie ein game game i fiction des terrors
nennen expertinnen dass eine davon ist
julia ebner
sie forscht in london da waren ganz
viele gaming referenzen und insider
witze aus der gaming szene drin
seither haben wir denke ich schon eine
verstärkte dem infizierte terrorszene
gesehen
der attentäter aus halle streamt ihr die
tat auftritt nennt außerdem sogenannte l
chapmans also erfolge zum beispiel juden
töten oder selbst überleben
das hat eine ganz große rolle auch dann
in online-communitys gespielt wo dann
zum beispiel dazu aufgerufen wurde den
bisher erfolgreichsten spieler sozusagen
zuzuschlagen das war anders eilig in
norwegen der die höchste opferzahl
erreicht hat bestenlisten mit
attentätern und massenmördern
tatsächlich sind sie online leicht zu
finden
high scores für single und multiplayer
auf dem singleplayer score steht der
massenmörder aus norwegen ganz oben
anders drei weg auf 7 finden die seiten
auf denen er verehrt wird
für die betreiber von steam ist das
offenbar kein problem
vor allen dingen möchtest die möglichst
wenig kunden vertrauen ist sie schreiben
selbst wollen sich nicht einmischen in
die freie meinungsäußerung ihrer kunden
nicht fassen wir mal zusammen
rechtsextremisten versuchen die gaming
community zu unterwandern
mal ganz komisch verpackt mal ganz
offensichtlich
und manch rechtsradikaler fühlt sich
ganz wohl in den gaming community
die letzten jahre haben gezeigt
terroristen inszenieren ihre taten als
computerspiel morden in heiß golden die
plattform machen wenig dagegen aus angst
kunden zu verlieren und für viele in der
gaming community sind hass und gewalt
ein richtiges nerv thema das ist einfach
so ein ganz ganz ekliger und zäher
kaugummi der immer und immer wieder
durchgekaut wird und bei dem einfach
schon so viele vorteile sind bevor man
also man man sagt dass und irgendwie
sind ganz viele sofort getriggert
entweder weil sie sagen stimmt nicht
oder weil sie sagen oh gott oh gott ja
stimmt die ganzen killer werden da
herangezüchtet
es ist einfach sehr sehr schwierig die
killerspiel debatte als anfang der
2000er mehrere menschen nach amokläufen
sterben geben politik und viele medien
computerspielen eine mitschuld
spiele wie dieses werden als killerspiel
bezeichnet manche fordern ein verbot von
ego shootern
dabei macht so was hier noch kein mörder
aus uns
keine wissenschaftliche studie konnte
belegen dass solche spiele allein zu
gewalt im echten leben führen also ja
die killerspiel debatte war überzogen
aber muss es deshalb für nazis zwischen
gamer innen so gemütlich sein
die gaming kultur ist grundsätzlich
nicht anfälliger für rechtsextreme
strömungen die andere kulturen aber sie
hat in den letzten jahren eben noch
nicht so die widerstände entwickelt wie
man sie jetzt bei spielen der fußball
kultur oder so beobachten kann wo es ja
auch zum beispiel julian kultur gibt die
aber auch eben durch die anderen fans
eben auch angegangen wird und wo wir
auch aktiv von abgegrenzt wird viele
gamer innen fällt es schwer sich
lautstark und sichtbar abzugrenzen
einfach nur zocken ohne gedanken an
killer und nazis zu verschwenden
dass das viele wollen verständlich ist
natürlich total doof oder auch gaming
generell weil die kriegen haid den
schmutz dann ab also die kriegen die
berufe ab obwohl der durchschnitts gamer
überhaupt nichts damit am hut hat du
bist vielleicht auch genervt davon aber
es gibt etwas was du tun kannst als teil
der community
wenn sie sich in diesem vorne weg und
dort beobachtet dass agitiert für das
video logi verteilt wird sollte auch sie
aktiv werden und es eben nicht
unkommentiert da stehen lassen und
mindestens melden bei den plattformen
was denkst du
müssen gamer in den lauter werden gegen
rechtsextreme in der szene
schreib es uns in die kommentare